o&o gewählt hallöchen freunde und
herzlich willkommen in einer neuen
debatte baseline folge sofort ich mach
das mal ganz kurz weg und sagt so wie
meine letzte mal hier stehengeblieben
haben wir geschaut ob hier etwas drin
ist dies war allerdings nicht der fall
und was wir nachher aufgefallen dass
gesehen werden auch einfach den
fackelträgern wenden können
weil damit doppelt so schnell runter
gekommen aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
nicht dass sich hier noch irgendetwas
befindet was nennenswert ist außer dass
wir uns hier vielleicht noch ein
bisschen sand abholen können
allerdings hat mir einer in die
kommentare geschrieben und das habe ich
mir durchgelesen das war ein spoiler und
das finde ich nicht so gut also dass ich
nicht so gut und zwar hat er geschrieben
dass wir noch locker 20 minuten laufen
müssen damit wir hier so ein paar
kakteen und sondern quatscht finden und
die farben fertig zu kriegen und so also
das soll wohl noch extrem lange dauern
bis wir annähernd irgendwas anderes
fertig haben sollen
deswegen wäre das jetzt einfach meine
frage an euch wollt ihr wirklich dass
ich einfach so total lustlos ohne
irgendwas zu machen einfach nur rum
laufen oder wollen wir wirklich sagen
dass ich hier vielleicht noch schön
irgendwann bauern tempel oder so und
dann hatten wir das projekt ab und
anfang etwas neues an alter die leute
sechs migranten bis hin zu laut 8 wieder
aufs volk gute harte oder wollt ihr
lieber dass ich wirklich einfach nur
jetzt noch so ein tempelbau oder so also
schreibt bitte einfach mal in die
kommentare ob er wollte dass ich
wirklich weil man muss echt 20 locker 20
minuten einfach nur geradeaus laufen und
sprinten
damit man irgendwas findet meinte er
also deswegen werdet jetzt meine frage
an euch wollte er dass ich so mir noch
ein bisschen zeit nehmen bei diesem
projekt dass ganz schnell ich angehe und
noch so ein tempelbau oder allgemein
irgendwas bauer sind dann tempel wie ich
bei kultur jahr gebaut habe oder
irgendwie sowas oder soll ich wirklich
mich absetzen und dann 20 minuten vor
natürliche pampa laufen also dürft ihr
entscheiden in dem fall ich glaube ich
weiß schon was ihr wollt und deswegen
würde ich einfach mal sagen schreibt in
die kommentare
und auch hatte mir die kommentare
geschrieben hey du hast oder gar keine
pilze wie du sagst du das denn ich hatte
das irgendwie schon abgehakt welcher so
ein pilz hatte und das war für mich
eigentlich schon erfahren weil ich
musste die nur noch irgendwo hinsetzen
sabine fahren musste ich einfach noch
einen dunklen raum machen ach du scheiße
das sind e mails viele monster das war
ein fuß der weg wird man da war gab auch
irgendwo ein kripo erhofft so viele
monster hilfe ja ich muss den pilz dann
halt einfach nur noch irgendwo hinsetzen
dann kann man es dem pilz vom nennen die
zombies haben immer noch keinen körper
und ihr braucht jetzt auch nicht alle
ist weil es mal so alle haben wir danach
nach der folge so text apex gesendet ich
möchte keine downloads an dem ich habe
nichts gegen reich aber ich kann euch
nicht sag ich mal so vertrauen das ich
weiß dass dort keine viren bei sind wie
sie es dann da eine crew ausgebüxt guck
mal näher kommen die kinder töten oder
getötet
die monster falle da habe ich auch noch
ein bisschen angst dass zwar das jetzt
mal ganz interessant ist also bei der
monster falle passiert ist als wir da
unten waren auf einmal alles in luft
geflogen ist
das sieht übrigens kunst aber das mache
ich jetzt gerade kaputt weil wir
brauchen heute so melonen farm haben war
und dort läuft ja alles ganz gut
eigentlich sagt da war glaube ich ein
paar kennen oder so wird es noch nicht
gewachsen so schön achte ich kann dir
auch schon wieder abfällen theoretisch
wenn ich in diamanten hätte kalt mir
sogar entscheiden wer bücher und so zu
kriegen das ist ja nicht allzu schwer
also mit zuckerrohr war egal dass ich
wieder ich war gar nicht wieder im game
ort und hat fotos gemacht ersetzt nicht
wiedererkannt sagt graf und bittet um
die verrückten gerade eilig sagt schön
hell was das betrifft als passiert
zwar startet ich schaue mal ganz kurz
das kann jeder noch so alles vage blabla
und bo mein gott die lippen habe ich
denn ich habe den bogen raus und weg ich
höre ihn nur ein beispiel aus einer ist
so was mal wolle kann ich mir eigentlich
auch noch mal neu aber nicht und nämlich
ein schwert eisen stimmt ich habe einen
stein sachen dann brauche ich komme
stone bild denn wenn hier und dort über
das skelett della sera und wollte ich
auch noch ich habe dort noch ausgleichen
diesem verbrennt das licht naja ok cool
ich habe jetzt drei jetzt müsse es passt
passt eher zu viel egal ob die stimme
egal so 12 ich brauche auch nicht wir
können theoretisch tnt machen wir können
übels viel tnt machen
thema was ich falsch mache weil ich
wüsste nicht wofür wir sonst das dingens
brauchen und dass nur platz wegnimmt
können wir das auch einfach dafür
verbrauchten c6 tnt eventuell können wir
das ja irgendwann hier benutzen
naja so gut war gott
verpiss dich doch bilder endermann wo
bist du wo bisher bot das alles voll mit
monstern
vielleicht sollte ich das dauernd noch
absperren oder so und darum ist noch
fleisch wir können die monster falle
reingucken das wird wahrscheinlich total
geil da unten jetzt sein obwohl er komme
ich gar nicht in welcher alles voll ist
aktuellen ein schuss nur geil ich also
sofort weg
würde
und für den brauch wieder auf weil er so
weit weg ist oder wat stehen gut da mit
ein paar items alter hier gibt es mir
echt krass ab wenn ich hier bin
dort ist auch schon wieder sein skelett
die falle läuft noch nicht so wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe also monster's
ball aber naja august schon wieder ein
bogen cool er komm runter kripo ich
knalle ich jetzt abbauen soll ein
skelett so olga tokarczuk rhetorik auch
lass mich in ruhe
in fast tot hilfe das essen so ihr meint
ja bau der pilz farben da möchte deshalb
braucht man denn eigentlich da fürchte
ich mache das einfach mal aus enstone
geht das also wir müssen glaube ich auf
erde gepflanzt werden
ich meine in den fenstern weil ich davon
einfach am meisten habe kam endlich
ihren baum war mir schon so eine kleine
fläche so reicht das von der größe ich
glaube das müsste passen also
cool ich glaube mehr platz brauchen wir
auch gar nicht oder mehr pilze ich mach
das jetzt alles nur hier gerade damit
die aufgaben dann fertig hat mich dann
um palast oder sowas kümmern kann wenn
ihr dafür seid also bitte einfach in die
kommentare
ich mach das so
ich meine das muss der stockfinster in
diesem raum sein
das heißt ich muss das da theoretisch zu
bauen oder setzt x und pilzen
ich hoffe nur dass da drin ja da wird
hundertprozentig irgendwann transporten
aber das kann ja nicht verhindern
freilich kann man theoretisch pisten zu
machen
aber der verbrauch redstone und dort
habe ich wiederum nicht naja ich rufe
mal ganz kurz wieder hier die challenges
auf und zwar sind noch challenges wir
sollen noch mehr lava finden also wir
sollen lover finden und einer kaktus
fahren nur die sache ist halt für lava
und für die kakteen müssen wir übels
welt laufen als wenn man jetzt auffällig
und wir haben es wirklich alles von
diesen weil sie nicht 30 challenges oder
wie viele das sind oder 20 geschafft bis
auf mehr lava und kakteen und das sind
jetzt sich alan joyce wo ich sage das
ist so wie die pilze zusätze einmal hast
es geschafft und dann kümmert sich da
gar nicht mehr darum und das find ich
halt eigentlich nicht so toll an
irgendwelchen challenges sondern die
sollten dann schon irgendeinen sinne
haben wie zb eine monster falle dass ich
dann immer abgeschossen werden oder so
dass sehr ganz toller sind die kommt ja
eigentlich dach aus da frage ich nicht
oder wo kommt alle acht die banken sich
dann nur aus but the cologne jetzt mal
kurz rein
o&o gewählt ich dachte schon es ist
nicht tot alter erscheint er richtig
party drin zu sein
bennys das schießt einer baracke sollte
man von oben up on me com ich lass das
mal sah alles ganz gut da warte wegen
der schönheit
so und jetzt oder und ist auch schon der
song creep ich verschwende die ganze
feier an diese blöden monster hier sonst
noch irgendwer ist schon pilz gewachsen
kann ja mal eben gucken oder das hier
kann ich auch mal ja wollt ihr plan
vielleicht sollte mit der oa ein kleines
baby ein kleines baby qnx gespannt und
auch nichts wachsen gut
also wir haben jetzt wirklich alles
fertig und dann würde ich einfach mal
sagen dass sie das dann in die
kommentare schreibt ich kann jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz in die falle da unten
gehen wo ich wahrscheinlich eh sofort
sterben werde
deswegen lasse ich meine ganzen sachen
schon mal hier jemand von den bogen mit
ich ich könnte steinen fenstern und so
weit noch mitnehmen damit dass da bis
hin zu bauen kann war da ist
so mädels
euro ist eh schon kommen dass alles voll
ich habe noch sechs pfeile das auch ganz
toll und ich kreiere platz
oh gott oh gott über 1000 ist wieder
party und da hat er den schlüssel da hat
er den trip da hat er den da hat er den
hat erinnerte bitte triple
so tritt ok leuten sind wieder
schallplatten und alles eher ganzes das
motto gott oh gott oh gott oh gott das
aber übels viele monster
ich glaube ich habe da gerade ein
skelett den kripo der hat einfallen
lassen der zombie das internet dann
können wir vielleicht auch endlich mal
irgendwann ein tolles eisen schwert
machen wo man nicht gehen darunter wer
direkt abgeschlossen ist sehr schön
kommt um die ecke mädels kommt ruhig um
die ecke kommt ruhig
hallo habe nur noch fünf eile und eine
musik ist man das ist wieder so ein
komischer bagdad - es vorab wegen weil
wegen too many alte madonna way but it
is so blöd man erschreckt mich doch
nicht so
die krise weg das wird mein leben
generiert sich nicht hilfe das herz geht
weg von mir weg nein ich schießen
vor knapp so erstmal wieder leben
generieren hier
puh das war schon krank so schön haben
wir noch eine musik ist super bringt
voll aber wenn jetzt viele arme schon
wir haben auch eisen ein eisen haben wir
dann kann es ebenfalls anreisen schwert
machen das ist dann bestimmt ganz cool
pfeil habe ich noch viele nämlich auch
nicht so übel stil wieder von den ganzen
anderen sda vier sand super und hat wird
wohl heute nichts mehr mit zu bauen
geh weg du was gutes wenn man skelett
abschieds kriegt man immer wieder von
teils zurück sag ich mal
oder ich könnte ja mal schauen ob ich
das hier alle stoppen kann
diese komischen wasserfluss in dem ich
jetzt erstmal kennen jeweils schon
danach wird aber dafür brauche ich
sandstorm momentan kann ich mir eben
machen
dann fallen die alle auf dieser ebene
und backen sich daraus ist aber dann
auch wieder blöd
ich stelle mir das so vor so jetzt
stapelt sich dass da alles und unten
kommen nicht mehr so viel in das heißt
die fallen jetzt alle daraufhin
verrecken da dann oder so ich muss das
da unten einfach mal richtig zu bauen
na ja das mache ich einfach gleich ins
man muss ich dann da unten erst mal alle
töten
na ja aber ich würde sagen darum kümmern
wir uns in der nächsten folge und zwar
schreibt mir doch jetzt ist man die
kommentare wollt ihr dass ich zehn
milliarden jahre lang rum lauf um einen
kaktus ein einmal lava zu finden
oder wollte er dass wir vielleicht noch
ein zwei folgen machen und noch ein paar
last versuchen zu bauen oder irgendwie
so einen wüsten tempel oder irgendwie
sowas also nix großes an referenten
anderes gebäude ist das hier datei ist
schreibt einmal den konter und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal typs